- If I hum something right now.
- Oh, I love competing.
Let's do it.
(audience laughing)
Let's do it, you're going down Buble.
- Yeah.
- I can see it in your eyes.
You got really
intense there.
- Yeah.
- Listen the iconic bit of note
is really what the thing is about,
you see me playing the piano.
I can name that song in five notes.
I can name that song in
four notes and what it is,
you get clues and you have to listen to--
- Bohemian Rhapsody.
Sorry.
(audience laughing)
All right.
- Queen.
- I'll stop.
- I would love it.
I love a game.
- Okay,
I'm gonna give you guys a clue.
- Okay, fine.
- There was a song that was so iconic,
it started it all in the musical TV genre.
- It started it all
with a musical TV genre.
- Okay, so is a theme show.
- It's not a theme song,
but it's from a show.
- Okay.
- Oh.
- I would, I mean.
(scatting)
Oh, I know what is is.
- No, no, no.
Listen to the clue.
- You just keep losing.
- Listen to the clue.
- Okay.
- See the clue's important.
- It was a crowning moment.
♪ What if I told you ♪
- I don't know, like A Moment Like This.
I'm going there.
- That's the one,
(screaming)
yeah, you got it!
You got it, you got it, you got it.
- Oh my God.
- You got it.
(audience applauding)
- Wait, wait.
- She not only sang it,
- No.
- it's hers and she got it.
- Nobody wants to guess it
when it's you, you sound like a tool.
It obviously had to be
A Moment Like This.
Oh my gosh, really?
- There's a little nepotism in this game.
- No, no, no, no, no no,
listen, listen.
- Yeah, but I didn't even
guess it.